David Boder: [In English] Munich, September the 20th, 1946, at the transient UNRRA camp at the Funkenkasernen. The interviewee is Miss...eh, is Mrs. Doctor Charlotte Schultze, 47 years old, and she is a [words not clear]. She is an Aryan, married to a Aryan physician who was here during the war, because they...for various reasons we will hear. And her husband and eleven year old son are already across, and she is expecting now, from week to week, her affidavits to go over to the United States.
David Boder: [In German] Also Frau Doktor, Sie wollen englisch sprechen, stimmt das?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein, deutsch.
David Boder: Sie wollen deutsch sprechen?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Gut. Kommen Sie ein bisschen näher, dann brauchen Sie nicht so laut zu sprechen. Machen Sie es sich bequem. [unverständlich; spricht sehr leise; allem Anschein, um das Mikrophon richtig zu plazieren]. Also Frau Doktor, wollen Sie mir nochmal sagen, wie heißen Sie und wo sind Sie geboren?
Charlotte Schultze: Charlotte Schultze—aus Dresden, also in Dresden geboren achtzehn hundert neun und neunzig (1899).
David Boder: Ja. Und wer waren Ihre Eltern?
Charlotte Schultze: Direktor Bruno Zumack und...
David Boder: Sie sind eine geborene Zumack?
Charlotte Schultze: Zumack, ja
David Boder: Und wer...was war die Beschäftigung Ihrer Eltern?
Charlotte Schultze: Mein Vater war Fabrik Direktor.
David Boder: Ja. Ein bisschen näher.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Und nun sagen Sie mir mal und wo waren Sie...wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg anfing?
Charlotte Schultze: Als der Krieg anfing waren wir in Dresden und konnten nicht zurück, da mein Sohn aus erster Ehe Deutscher war und nicht mehr aus dem Land gelassen wurde.
David Boder: Aha.
Charlotte Schultze: Weil er arbeitsfähig war.
David Boder: Also hätte man nicht Sie selber rüber gelassen?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, mich hätte man rüber gelassen, aber ich wollte meinen Sohn nicht alleine lassen, nicht wahr.
David Boder: Sie wollten Ihren Sohn nicht allein lassen. Und war Ihr Mann damit einverstanden?
Charlotte Schultze: Oh ja. [seufzt] Es ging ja nicht anders.
David Boder: Also, nun sagen Sie mal...also, hm, wie lange...ich verstehe, dass Sie schon einmal in Amerika gelebt haben.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Also wann sind Sie dann nach Deutschland zurück gekommen?
Charlotte Schultze: Neunzehn hundert vier und dreißig (1934) weil meine Mutter starb und mein Vater Sehnsucht hatte nach uns und wir unseren kleinen Jungen erwarteten und [lacht etwas]...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . und die Grosseltern ihn eben...
David Boder: Wollten.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . sehen wollten, nicht. [lacht etwas]
David Boder: Ja. Und da kamen Sie mit Ihrem Mann zurück?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Wo hat Herr Dr. Schultze studiert?
Charlotte Schultze: In Leipzig.
David Boder: In Leipzig hat er Medizin studiert?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Ja. Nun und, hm, so kamen Sie alle zurück?
Charlotte Schultze: Kamen wir alle zurück, ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie was in Amerika hinterlassen?
Charlotte Schultze: Wir haben, hm,...
David Boder: Haben Sie welche Vermögen...
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie das gelassen, in Milwaukee?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, in New York.
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Mein Mann hat...hat da eine Lebensversicherung drüben
David Boder: War er im Stande die ganzen Zeit die Lebensversicherung weiter aufrecht zu erhalten?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein, das ging durch...durch, hm. Anleihen...hat sich das...
David Boder: Oh, es konnte durch eine Anleihe auf die Versicherung...
Charlotte Schultze: . . . das zahlen.
David Boder: . . . das weiter...
Charlotte Schultze: . . . das zahlen, nicht.
David Boder: Nun und Sie kamen hier her und dann hat Ihr Mann die Praxis der Medizin wieder aufgenommen?
Charlotte Schultze: Erst hat er hier Sch...Kurse genommen, und deshalb waren wir eigentlich rüber gekommen.
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Wurden aber dann hier fest gehalten durch die Krankheit seines Vaters...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . der eine Augen...eine schwere Augenoperation durchmachen musste und wir dadurch nicht wieder zurück kehren konnten die erste Zeit.
David Boder: Was ist dem Doktor seine Spezialität? Hat er welche?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein, er war ein...
David Boder: Allgemeine...allgemeine Praxis.
Charlotte Schultze: Er war ein praktischer Arzt.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie mir dann sagen, was hat dann passiert wenn der Krieg angefangen...anfing?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, wir blieben dann hier und...
David Boder: Sie lebten in Dresden?
Charlotte Schultze: Wir lebten in Dresden, mein Mann praktizierte da und...
David Boder: Sie sagten mir bevor, dass etwas mit Ihrem Jungen...mit dem Ältesten vor sich gegangen ist. Wollen Sie mir das sagen?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja. Mein Sohn war dann der Einzige in der Schule, der nicht zur Hitler Jugend gehörte und, hm, da mein Mann viele jüdische Patienten behandelte, hatte er sich einen Freund angeschafft, der Jude war und dadurch hatten wir, hm, sehr viele Schwierigkeiten. Und...nachdem ein Jahr Krieg war, versuchte er über die Schweizer Grenze zu entkommen mit seinem Freund, um uns den Weg frei zu machen wieder nach Amerika zu gehen, weil er wusste, dass er der...
David Boder: Die Hinderung.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . Hinderungspunkt war, nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Und da wurde er fest gehalten an der Schweizer Grenze. Die zwei Jungs wurden drei Monate ins Gefängnis geschickt und dann habe ich die Beiden in Bregenz wieder abgeholt.
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Und von da an waren wir immer ziemlich unter Beobachtung der Gestapo.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Dann kam der Junge zum Arbeitsdienst. Da hat er nochmal versucht das Lager zu verlassen, wurde aber dann wieder zurück geholt. Dann wurde er eingezogen neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941).
David Boder: Als Soldat?
Charlotte Schultze: Als Soldat. Und war dann so unglücklich, weil er eben glaubte, er kann nicht für diese Sache dienen und...
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Jedenfalls neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) hat er dann wieder die Truppe verlassen und hat versucht über die italienische Grenze zu gehen, weil ein amerikanischer Pfarrer, der in unserer Kirche war, mit dem er sehr befreundet war, von dem er wusste, dass er in Rom in der Botschaftskirche—ein gewisser Pfarrer [unverständlich] Wolf...
Charlotte Schultze: . . . von Elmira.
David Boder: War das ein amerikanischer Pfarrer?
Charlotte Schultze: Ein amerikanischer Pfarrer.
David Boder: Von Elmira, New Jersey.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, mit dem er sehr, sehr befreundet war.
David Boder: Elmira, New York?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, und?
Charlotte Schultze: Und...also wir nehmen an, dass das der Grund war, warum er gerade über die italienische Grenze ging.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Und von dort...von da an wissen wir nichts mehr. Uns hat dann die Gestapo seine Sachen gebracht und behauptete er hätte sich erschossen.
David Boder: Ach so, die Gestapo hat Ihnen seine Sachen gebracht?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, aber ich weiß heute noch nicht...
David Boder: Hat er keinen Brief hinterlassen?
Charlotte Schultze: Gar nichts.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, warum hat sich die Gestapo überhaupt darum gekümmert seine Sachen zu bringen?
Charlotte Schultze: Hm. Ja, das wissen wir auch nicht. Jedenfalls haben wir erst nach drei (3) Wochen, nachdem wir überall Vermissten Anzeigen gemacht haben und alles - dann bekamen wir erst mal nach über drei (3) Wochen, da bekamen wir erst mal Bescheid, dass er überhaupt tot war. Und man hatte ihn beerdigt auf italienischem Boden.
David Boder: Oh, auf italienischem Boden.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja. Wahrscheinlich...[beide sprechen]
David Boder: Ja, zu dieser Zeit waren die Italiener schon mit den Deutschen in Verbündnis, nicht wahr? Es war Mussolini’s Italien.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja. [seufzt]
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, Sie sind dann...und ihr jüngerer Junge, wie alt war der?
Charlotte Schultze: Der Junge ist jetzt elf (11) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Elf (11) Jahre, er war niemals in Amerika?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein. Er ist also...wir sind im Oktober hier her und im Dezember ist er geboren worden.
David Boder: Und er ist im Dezember geboren.
Charlotte Schultze: Hm.
David Boder: Nun und was hat der Doktor die ganze Zeit getan?
Charlotte Schultze: Er hat praktiziert in Dresden.
David Boder: Er hat in Dresden als Arzt praktiziert.
Charlotte Schultze: Praktiziert.
David Boder: Konnten Sie ihn nicht einberufen?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein. Er hat immer seine amerikanische Bürgerschaft aufrecht erhalten. Bekam allerdings dadurch keine Krankenkassen zugewiesen und...
David Boder: Ja. Ja. Und er ist ein geborener Amerikaner?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, er ist drüben geboren, ja.
David Boder: Ja. Einem Deutschen würde man das nicht erlaubt haben. Sagen Sie mir, wenn ein Deutscher nachher ein amerikanischer Bürger geworden wäre, dann hätten die Deutschen das nicht anerkannt?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, er war naturalisiert. Er war zwar drüben geboren...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . und ist dann als Kind wieder zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Ja?
Charlotte Schultze: Und hat sich dann erst naturalisieren lassen.
David Boder: Nochmal?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Weil er dadurch seine Staatsbürgerschaft verloren hatte.
David Boder: Ja. Weil er als Kind zurück gekommen ist?
Charlotte Schultze: Wie bitte?
David Boder: Weil er als Kind zurück gebracht wurde?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, weil...
David Boder: Er wurde von seinen Eltern zurück gebracht?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Aha, nun, also sagen Sie mir, Sie haben in Dresden gelebt?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Wie ist es in Dresden während des Krieges vorgegangen? Ich habe so viel gehört von Leuten, die in Lagern waren, aber so wenig gehört von Leuten, die frei waren. Wie ging das in Dresden vor sich?
Charlotte Schultze: Oh, wir hatten so nichts.
David Boder: Also, wie ist es dort zugegangen?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja—für uns persönlich—wir durften nur die Stadt nicht verlassen.
David Boder: Warum?
Charlotte Schultze: Wegen der Staatsangehörigkeit.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Ah hm. Ja und sonst...es war...wir waren alle eben unter strenger Bewachung [lacht etwas]. Niemand durfte sprechen, was er wollte [lacht].
David Boder: So, ja. Haben Sie Ihr Radio behalten?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, wir konnten das Radio behalten.
David Boder: Sie durften das Radio behalten?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, wir durften nur keine fremden Sender hören. Das heißt, ich hab’s getan, indem ich Kopfhörer hatte. [lacht]
David Boder: Ah, Sie hatten hm, hm, Ohren...[lacht]
Charlotte Schultze: Kopfhörer. [lacht]
David Boder: Kopfhörer...und so konnten Sie mehr oder weniger...haben Sie geglaubt, was die ausländischen Sender...[beide sprechen]
Charlotte Schultze: Die konnte ich jeden Abend hören und dadurch waren wir doch über alles orientiert.
David Boder: Aha.
Charlotte Schultze: Und dadurch, dass mein Mann sehr viele, hm, jüdische Patienten hatte, waren wir auch orientiert über alles, was vorkam, indem er einen Patienten hatte, der aus Buchenwald kam und seine Kopfschwarte vollkommen zerschlagen war und alles. Ein gewisser Doktor Magen...
David Boder: Ach, ein Doktor, der in Buchenwald war, nicht?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Wieso haben die ihn heraus gelassen?
Charlotte Schultze: Gut, die haben ihn für eine kurze Zeit eingesperrt. Und zwar war er der Vater des Jungen mit dem mein Sohn da...
David Boder: Weg gegangen ist.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . über die Grenze gegangen war.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Und dieser Herr Dr. Magen war dann nach Buchenwal gekommen und dann haben sie ihn wieder frei gelassen. Dann nach einem Jahr wieder eingesperrt. Und, hm, damit war er so unglücklich und hat sich dann in der Zelle das Leben genommen, indem er seine Wäsche zerrissen hat und sich aufgehängt hat.
David Boder: Das war der Doktor Magen?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Und was hat seinem Sohn passiert?
Charlotte Schultze: Und dessen Sohn hat dann später auch noch einmal versucht die Schweizer Grenze zu erreichen, ist aber dann auch erwischt worden und man hat...
David Boder: Haben sie...ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . ihn in ein Konzentrationslager gebracht und dann nach einigen Wochen hat man der Mutter und der Tochter, die beide noch übrig blieben, die Wäsche geschickt und den Vermerk, dass er gestorben wäre.
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Und dann wurden die Mutter und die Tochter...die kamen dann in eine Baracke und später nach Polen. Seitdem haben wir nie wieder etwas gehört von den beiden.
David Boder: Und der Mann? Und er hat sich das Leben genommen?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, er hat sich das Leben genommen.
David Boder: Wo?
Charlotte Schultze: In Dresden, im Gefängnis, weil er hörte, dass er wieder in ein Konzentrations-Führungslager kommen wird, nicht.
David Boder: Aha.
Charlotte Schultze: Da war er so verzweifelt, dass er...
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, wie war das im Allgemeinen mit Selbstmord? Gab es da viel davon?
Charlotte Schultze: Ich...ich könnte das nicht so sagen. Unter den jüdischen Leuten natürlich sehr viel, mein Mann ist oft zu Patienten gerufen worden unter anderem zu einer gewissen Frau Pick...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . die bei uns in der Nähe wohnte, eine alte, sehr feine Dame von siebzig (70) Jahren. Sie...meistens nahmen sie sich das Leben mit Veronal.
David Boder: Mit Veronal, mit den Schlaftabletten?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, ja. [seufzt] Mein Mann ist auch zu einem Herrn Fisch gerufen worden, der, als damals der Abtransport nach Polen war...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . und der Mann war schwer krank und sollte noch in der Nacht nach Polen verschickt werden. Und da hat mein Mann selbst die Gestapo angerufen und hat...und...
David Boder: Gesagt.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . und gemeldet hat, dass es unmöglich ist, diesem Mann...
David Boder: Mit zu nehmen.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . mit zu nehmen, nicht. Dann sind nur die Söhne abtransportiert worden, weil die Polen waren, das heißt, die waren nie in Polen gewesen.
David Boder: Ja—nur polnische Bürger.
Charlotte Schultze: Sie waren in Deutschland geboren, nicht wahr. Die Leute wurden dann an der Grenze dort abgesetzt und...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . kein Mensch hat sich mehr um sie gekümmert.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, Sie haben ja auch mit Deutschen verkehrt, nicht wahr?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie haben sich die Deutschen zu der ganzen Hitler Geschichte verhalten?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, wir hatten jedenfalls das Gefühl, dass eher sehr, sehr Wenige für Hitler waren...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . denn ich weiß, dass in meines Mannes Praxis wohl kaum ein Prozent Nazis waren.
Charlotte Schultze: Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass diejenigen, die zu uns kamen, nicht [lacht]...weil sie wussten erstens, dass mein Mann Amerikaner ist und zweitens wussten sie unsere Einstellung.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, hat man gewusst, was in Konzentrationslagern vor geht?
Charlotte Schultze: Ach doch, ich denke die Mehrzahl der Menschen nicht.
David Boder: Sie glauben die Mehrzahl...
Charlotte Schultze: Nein, nein, hat’s nicht gewusst.
David Boder: Nun...
Charlotte Schultze: Wenn wir...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Wenn wir nicht zufällig durch die Patientenschaft Vieles gehört hätten, hätten wir es auch nicht gewusst.
David Boder: Nun sind da nicht Gestapo Leute nach Hause gekommen und haben es ihren Verwandten erzählt, Bekannten und so weiter?
Charlotte Schultze: Hm, ja, es...
David Boder: Man kann doch das nicht so [unverständlich].
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls stand ja bei jedem die Todesstrafe.
David Boder: jedem Gestapo Mann?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, es konnte ja niemand sprechen. Man musste ja so vorsichtig sein. Auch ich hatte oft Angst, wenn mein Mann spät aus der Praxis kam [seufzt und lacht etwas], dass etwas passiert ist.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Weil er auch oft zu frei geredet hat. [lacht etwas]
David Boder: Aha.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, es war ja alles so furchtbar gefährlich. Es kann sich gar niemand drüben im Amerika einen Begriff davon machen, wie sehr man eben unter Kontrolle stand und um welche Anzeichen die Bevölkerung lebte.
David Boder: Nun...[Pause]...sagen Sie, haben Sie Ihre Dienstmädchen behalten während des Krieges?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja...ja.
David Boder: Und was für eine Person war die? Was haben Sie von der zum Beispiel, was für Ideen hat die geäußert?
Charlotte Schultze: Oh, ich hatte ein sehr nettes Mädchen aus...aus Finster...na, na, aus der Nähe von Finsterwalde—aus einem kleinen Ort da. Die Eltern hatten ein Gut und waren auch vollkommen gegen Hitler eingestellt. Also in dieser Weise [lacht] gab’s da keine Gefahr.
David Boder: Es war nicht gefährlich?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein, wir konnten da ganz offen reden, denn die Eltern waren genau so eingestellt wie wir. Dadurch war in der Weise keine Gefahr. Ebenso hatte ich eine Aufwartefrau, die meine Wäsche mit wusch und so weiter. Der ihr Mann war auch vollkommen gegen Hitler und auch sie. Also es war eigentlich in unserer ganzen Nachbarschaft und Bekanntschaft war niemand für das System.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, wer war eigentlich für das System, dass es so...[klingt wie das Ende vom Tonband]
Herman Barnett: [In English] Spool 137 recording starts in about one minute. Spool 137 recording starts in about one minute. This is Herman Barnett.
David Boder: Spool 9-137A. The conclusion of interview with Miss Charlotte Schultze. Spool 9-137B will contain the interview with Jürgen Bassfreund—a part of it.
David Boder: Munich, September the 20th, 1946 in a transient camp maintained by the UNRRA. The interviewee is Miss...Charlotte, Mrs. Charlotte Schultze, the wife pf a physician already in the United States and we have yet a short conclusion.
David Boder: [In German] Also sagen Sie mir, wir sprechen nochmal darüber, hm, was die Deutschen, sagen wir, wussten von Hitler und von Konzentrationslagern und vom Krieg. Zum Beispiel, was haben Sie über den Krieg gedacht?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, das ist so schwer zu sagen. Jeder hoffte nur, dass der Krieg bald zu Ende...bald zum Ende kommen würde und jeder hoffte beinah, dass wir ihn nicht gewinnen, weil jeder Angst davor hatte, was dann werden sollte, wenn die Nazis gewinnen würden.
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: So traurig, wie das klingt, aber...es war wirklich in den meisten Fällen so.
David Boder: Haben Sie nicht gefühlt, dass Deutschland angegriffen wurde und sich jetzt verteidigen mus?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein, darüber war sich wohl fast jeder klar, dass Hitler derjenige war, der angriff. [lacht etwas]
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, also wenn es solch eine Stimmung war, wie erklärt man sich die Stärke, diese große Anzahl von SS und die große Anzahl von SA und, hm, die großen Kundgebungen immer wenn Hitler sprach und so weiter?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, die Leute waren ja alle dazu befohlen.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel, wer?
Charlotte Schultze: Also die ganzen...die Schulen mussten kommen und mussten schreien. Die Hitler Jugend war befohlen, die ganzen Betriebe mussten geschlossen marschieren und mussten ,Heil Hitler’ schreien. Es hatte ja niemand mehr einen eigenen Willen außer einigen freien Berufen.
David Boder: Und welche freien Berufe waren das?
Charlotte Schultze: Also Rechtsanwälte und irgend...Menschen, die nicht organisiert waren.
David Boder: Nun was denken Sie...nun möchte ich Ihnen noch eine Frage stellen. Ist es, wie Sie sich denken, ist es wahr, dass es den Deutschen eigentlich jetzt nicht so schlecht geht?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, wir hier in der amerikanischen Zone, wir können uns ja schließlich nicht beschweren.
David Boder: [beide sprechen] Ich meine das deutsche Publikum im Allgemeinen.
Charlotte Schultze: Im Allgemeinen, ich meine der Feind ist sehr anständig zu uns; ganz im Gegensatz dazu, wie wir wahrscheinlich in anderen Ländern waren.
David Boder: Nun.
Charlotte Schultze: Wir haben wohl Länder gekannt...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . die fast verhungert sind, als unsere Besatzung drüben war, weil ja alles weg ge...geschafft worden ist von anderen Ländern, weil bei uns der Feind noch die Lebensmittel her bringt. [lacht etwas]
Charlotte Schultze: [kichert] In der Weise müssen wir ja hier sehr dankbar sein.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, wie erklären Sie, dass die Hauptvaluta da sozusagen die Zigarette ist? Wie ist das doch?
Charlotte Schultze: Die...
David Boder: Wollen die Leute wirklich so stark rauchen, dass sie so viel für Zigaretten hingeben wollen?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, darüber kann ich schwer reden, weil ich selbst Nichtraucherin bin [lacht] Und so...
David Boder: Na ja. Aber, zum Beispiel, man bezahlt einen Träger mit zwei (2) Zigaretten. Man gibt dem Mädel ein Trinkgeld mit zwei (2) Zigaretten. Was machen die damit?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, die verkauft das am „schwarzen Markt“ einfach.
David Boder: Wer kauft sie?
Charlotte Schultze: Das weiß ich nicht. [kichert] Ich nicht. [lacht]
David Boder: Nun ja, sagen Sie mir was kann man austauschen für zwei (2) Zigaretten?
Charlotte Schultze: Darüber kann ich sehr schwer Auskunft geben, weil ich eben nicht rauche.
David Boder: Aber Sie bekommen ja auch hier mit Zigaretten bezahlt und so weiter.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, das ist vielleicht nicht richtig.
David Boder: Ja, aber sie haben auch selber kein Geld und sagen, sie sagen, sie können für das Geld nichts bekommen.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, das weiß ich auch nicht. [flüstert]
David Boder: Na ja, tauschen die Bauern für Zigaretten?
Charlotte Schultze: Auch—sicher, wenn sie starke Raucher sind.
David Boder: Wenn...und die geben ziemlich viel dafür?
Charlotte Schultze: Die geben viel dafür. Ich habe gehört, dass jemand neunzig (90) Mark für ein Paket Zigaretten gezahlt hat.
David Boder: Neunzig (90) Mark
Charlotte Schultze: Neunzig (90) Mark.
David Boder: Nun ja, man zahlt in Frankreich dafür hundert fünfzig (150), hundert fünf und siebzig Franc.
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, das ist etwas, was hier die meisten Leute nicht verstehen.
David Boder: Hm. Sagen Sie mir jetzt noch, wie erklären Sie das, dass die meisten Deutschen so gut gekleidet sind?
Charlotte Schultze: Viele haben noch Vorräte gehabt, die die ihr Heim erhalten haben, aber die Meisten gehen ja doch nicht mehr so gut gekleidet, hm? Sehen Sie, die Meisten sind ja ausgebombt und irgendwie haben alles verloren, nicht.
David Boder: Nun wo ist all die Kleidung geblieben, die man von den Juden weg genommen hat, sagen wir in Theresienstadt und die man allen weg genommen hat, bevor man sie alle transportiert hat?
Charlotte Schultze: Hm, Sie müssen daran denken, dass die Städte alle ausgebrannt sind, nicht wahr und dass doch die ganzen Sachen in Flammen aufgegangen sind.
David Boder: So Sie denken, dass das alles...
Charlotte Schultze: Schauen Sie, es ist doch alles weg. Nehmen Sie einmal Dresden...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Dresden ist doch vollkommen zerstört und damit doch auch die ganzen Kleidungsstücke und alles. Wir sind, zum Beispiel, aus unserem Haus raus nur mit dem, was ich auf dem Leib hatte. Alles Andere war weg.
David Boder: Oh Sie wurden ausgebombt in Dresden?
Charlotte Schultze: Vollkommen ausgebombt.
David Boder: Wann hat das passiert?
Charlotte Schultze: Am dreizehnten (13.) Februar fünf und vierzig (45).
David Boder: Was war da? Eine Luftattacke? Von wem?
Charlotte Schultze: Weiß nicht, es war nacht.
David Boder: Bei Nacht?
Charlotte Schultze: Eine Nachtattacke. [seufzt]
David Boder: Und da war ein großes Bombardement?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, ein Großes...[beide sprechen]
David Boder: Und wo haben Sie sich mit der Familie in Sicherheit gesetzt?
Charlotte Schultze: Wir waren in einem Sammelschutzraum am Bahnhof.
David Boder: Aha.
Charlotte Schultze: Dresden hatte keinen einzigen Bunker, war also vollkommen ohne Schutz.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Nur der Stadthalter hatte einen großen Bunker für seine Familie. [beide sprechen]
David Boder: Wieso gibt es das, dass [unverständlich; beide sprechen] gegraben hat?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, ich glaube, dass hängt wohl am...am Gauleiter.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Von ihm.
David Boder: Nun also, sie gingen zur Station. Das war ja der gefährlichstePlatz!
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, wir waren erst in unserem Keller bei dem ersten Angriff.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Und, hm, dabei wurde unser Haus nicht verletzt. Es fielen nur Brandbomben in der Nähe.
Charlotte Schultze: Und dann gingen wir in die Neustadt, um nach unseren alten Eltern zu sehen.
David Boder: Ihre Eltern oder die Ihres Mannes?
Charlotte Schultze: Meine Eltern. Mein Schwiegervater starb dann mit vier und achtzig (84) Jahren nach dem Angriff.
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Und meine Schwiegermutter lebt noch mit acht und siebzig Jahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Und auch mein Vater. Und als wir von dort weg gingen, um nach Haus zu gehen, kam der zweite (2.) Alarm und da erreichten...
David Boder: [unverständlich; beide sprechen]
Charlotte Schultze: . . . erreichten wir unser Haus nicht mehr. Und mussten dann im Bahnhof unterkommen, im Bahnhofschutzraum.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Und...
David Boder: War dieser Bahnhofschutzraum unter der Erde?
Charlotte Schultze: Unter der Erde, ja.
David Boder: Oh, es waren diese Bahnstege, die unter der Erde für Fußgänger...
Charlotte Schultze: Nein, nein. Es waren diese Sammelschutzräume der Eisenbahn-Direktion.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: In einem ganz großen Backsteinhaus.
Charlotte Schultze: Da sind allerdings, ich glaube, hunderte von Menschen umgekommen. Und wie durch ein Wunder sind wir heraus gekommen, da heißt, mein Sohn, mein Kleiner und ich. Wir sind vielleicht nachts um zwei (2) Uhr durch eine Lucke heraus geklettert...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . und...
David Boder: Ihr Mann?
Charlotte Schultze: Mein Mann erst am nächsten Morgen um acht (8).
David Boder: Aha.
Charlotte Schultze: So haben wir dann den ganzen Tag gedacht mein Mann war tot und er hat von uns gedacht, wir wären tot.
David Boder: Aha, Sie haben nicht...er hat nicht gewusst, dass die raus kamen.
Charlotte Schultze: Nein. Wir haben uns dann erst am nächsten Abend getroffen.
David Boder: Zu Hause?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein, unser Haus war inzwischen auch weg.
David Boder: Oh, das Haus war weg?
Charlotte Schultze: Vollkommen zertrümmert.
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Die Praxis war vollkommen zertrümmert
Charlotte Schultze: Das Haus unserer Schwiegereltern ist weg.
David Boder: Hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Als meines Vater. Also wir sind alle vollkommen ausgebombt.
David Boder: War Dresden wirklich so schwer...
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, es ist vollkommen zerstört.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Die ganze Innenstadt. Auch mein Bruder ist tot und alle meine Freundinnen.
David Boder: Wieso, Ihr Bruder wurde im Bombardement getötet?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja wurde er, er kam auch mit um, ja.
David Boder: Und was ist mit Ihren alten Leuten passiert?
Charlotte Schultze: Meine Schwiegereltern, die haben sich noch heraus ge...gewühlt aus, aus all dem Schutt.
David Boder: Also es war bombardiert das Haus und Sie haben ihnen heraus geholfen?
Charlotte Schultze: Ja, heraus geholfen.
David Boder: Und?
Charlotte Schultze: Und sind dann bis nach Thüringen gekommen, ihre Heimat.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Und da ist dann mein Schwiegervater noch in der Nacht wegen Herzschwäche zu Grunde gegangen. Es war eigentlich traurigerweise, da er als junger Mann von 20 Jahren aus Thüringen weg gegangen ist, erst nach Schweden, dann nach Amerika...
Charlotte Schultze: . . . und ist an seinem Todestag...
David Boder: Wieder in Thüringen...
Charlotte Schultze: . . . wieder in Thüringen gelandet, um zu sterben. Ein eigenartiges Schicksal!
David Boder: Und Ihre Schwiegermutter?
Charlotte Schultze: Meine Schwiegermutter lebt noch in Coburg.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Charlotte Schultze: Die haben wir dann nach Coburg gebracht, damit sie in der amerikanischen Zone bleiben kann.
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: Sehen Sie, dass sie mit uns in Verbindung bleibt.
David Boder: Aha.
Charlotte Schultze: Und Dresden gehört zur russischen Zone.
David Boder: Und wer unterstützt sie?
Charlotte Schultze: Vorläufig hat sie genug zum Leben und wir hoffen, dass wir etwas von drüben [lacht etwas] was zum Essen schicken können.
David Boder: Aha.
Charlotte Schultze: Vielleicht können wir auch...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
David Boder: Haben Ihre Bekannten in Amerika Ihnen was geschickt während dieser Zeit?
Charlotte Schultze: Nein. Wir haben Briefe bekommen, aber weil alle hofften, dass wir schon eher zurück kommen,...
David Boder: Ja.
Charlotte Schultze: . . . haben sie gedacht, es lohnt sich nicht. [lacht]
David Boder: Nun, aber jetzt werden Sie ja schon bald in Amerika sein.
Charlotte Schultze: Hoffentlich, ja. [lacht]
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Mrs. Charlotte Schultze, wife of a physician, hm, what they call here a German Aryan, who is now in the United States with the child, and will probably send over the affidavit for the wife...for his wife. We conclude the interview at 8 minutes of the counter index. An Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording. Munich, Germany. September the 20th, 1946.
David Boder: [In German] Danke sehr, Frau Doktor.
Charlotte Schultze: Na also dann...
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 137A. The other part will be Spool 137B and is the beginning of Bassfreund’s story. It may be advisable since we have only 8 minutes on this spool to combine this one with 136B and have Mrs. Charlotte Schultze all on one spool. But we will leave that for further checkup. Boder. October the 13th, 1950. MH156.